c'est cassé
ouais
[Musique]
wow
Okay
C clair pour l'
option et super merci
tu n'es pas obligé de dire merci à
chaque
fois je pense que c'est parce que c'est la première
heure je vais être impoli
envers les
fréquences
[Musique]
tur
[Musique  ]
61 suivez
mil
21 clair pour l'
option clair pour l'option
ouais c'était un joli
coup et vous savez, pour terminer le coup,
laissez-le aussi comme ça mais euh aussi nous pouvons faire,
c'est peut-être comme euh finir euh arrêter l'
hélicoptère en quelque sorte  comme juste le faire se
couvrir, n'est-ce pas, nous pouvons aimer avancer
et ensuite euh faire en sorte que l'hélicoptère
s'arrête même s'il ne l'arrête pas vraiment,
cela fait un effet et ça
marche en quelque sorte Ser ouais
oh est-ce là-bas
alors alors Ben  pouvez-vous réduire
votre vitesse en arrière, prêt ouais, juste
juste pour une
seconde,
freinez,
nous essayons d'y mettre fin, nous avons juste
besoin d'une sorte de point de coupure
pour le trafic,
alors voyez, R Bernard devrait être juste à la sortie.
rue ici
ouais R juste au bord d'un petit
lac
en bas, j'ai quelqu'un derrière
Ok, je suis arrivé ouais, nous sortirons
ici,
ok,
bien et quand tu t'inclines, vas-y un peu lentement,
euh-huh, ok, comme si tous les mouvements étaient
plus lents, à droite  d'accord parce que j'ai peur
que le grand écran aille trop vite,
ok, continue de me fouetter jusqu'à ce que je le fasse correctement, s'il te plaît, dis
oui, mec, tu dois vraiment le supplier, c'était si ok, cette
vitesse, oui,
c'était ok, merci merci,
ici, ok, pars  ça roule un peu oh ouais oh
ouais tu comprends une partie que j'ai
compris c'est dur c'est difficile de faire
des plans de deux minutes ouais je veux dire juste ton instinct est
de le rendre beaucoup
plus court ouais parce que c'est vraiment long 2
minutes en fait ou même une minute c'est
long ouais  exactement
sur la planète Terre, comme certains des
zooms sur le 40 pour un, cela prendrait tellement
de temps et euh et d'abord, ils s'en sont plaints,
puis ils ont
réalisé que cela fonctionnait en fait pour
eux, vous savez, et ils ont aimé ça
et  comme oh tu dois le faire oh ouais, est-ce que ce
serait des maisons qui ont été
brûlées tu penses ouais où étaient-elles il y a
des maisons juste en dessous de moi wow tu as
raison tu le vois ouais
Cercle en arrière un peu il n'y a pas de
lumière sur elles peut-être que nous  je peux
trouver que c'est incroyable juste cette petite
section ouais
wow penser différemment à mon propre
quartier
maintenant tu sais je veux dire vraiment tu penses que
ton quartier est vraiment
invulnérable peut-être parce qu'il est
là depuis si
longtemps
mais bon je vais devoir changer le
filtre ok euh
ok  vas-y et K ok
tu non non ok vite tu as 10
secondes
sans
jeu et
approche en classe
Bravo soutien-gorge
que
wow ça s'en va comme
ouais dans le fils ouais il va on s'accroche
on doit faire quelque chose ouais je
sais exactement je  peut commencer à
tourner est-ce que tu as vraiment besoin de
tourner non j'en ai quelques milliers à faire
ok ok est-ce
qu'on en a assez va essayer
autre chose oh ouais jouer avec ça
ok oh ça a même l'air
mieux wow j'aime ça
ouais oh il est complètement R  derrière un chien
ouais, c'est sauvage, ça a
l'air
apocalyptique, toutes ces sortes de
situations, comme avec le soleil, les nuages
et tout ce que nous pouvons aimer, mettez-les quand
nous voulons dans le film si nous le voulons, peut-
être que nous ne l'utiliserons pas mais cela pourrait être
une transition
quoi qu'il en soit, c'est toujours
0, ok, tête